[Music]
I think through a lot of different
factors I came together for stage 19 to
to really take place
at the start of the Giro over in
Jerusalem I had crashed in the in the
Recon of the time trial and before the
race even begun some crashes you get up
from and brush it off and you're fine
but this one I wasn't right I wasn't
right and I felt for at least the first
ten days of the race I just wasn't
myself I felt out of balance out of
synch and I was hemorrhaging time also I
was losing time at every opportunity
pretty much lets across we knew that
could be crashes Chris Froome is down
Chris Froome is auditory opening to this
talk and I found myself coming into
stage 19 over three minutes down and I
knew it would take something absolutely
crazy to turn the race upside down and
it would be a kind of move of almost a
suicide move would be all or nothing
that idea of going solo ATK's out was a
decision I made in the morning before
the race I sent a message to my coach
Tim garrison and just said to him it's a
bit of a bit of a crazy move but what do
you think if I went ATK's out there's
only three climbs two descents it's
gonna be a Time Trial and behind that
they could have to sort out a really
good chase if if they want to catch me I
mean and he replied and his reply was a
little bit along the lines of he didn't
say no but he said listen take a lot of
work to do something like that I mean it
was it was going to be one of the
biggest days on the bike in my life in
terms of energy expenditure so how do I
fuel for a stage like that I had to
think about how much fuelling I need to
get in before the race and then again
once I got into the race how often do I
feel
on what and basically going at a time
trial as hard as I could certainly they
were doubt it's something that could go
completely wrong and you know what if it
doesn't work out then you lose
everything but on the other side I was
also thinking about it as well I'm
feeling good I'm feeling better in
myself now I'm gonna get out there and
go into time trauma as things developed
out on the road and simon yates had
started dropping eases right near the
back yeah Jersey that's not good that's
not good we hit the foot of the the
finestra and the team I asked the guys
to ramp it up through all the hair pins
earlier on and make the race harder and
harder so for the guys further back it
would have been quite tough for Eddie
they're basically stuck they're not just
riding tempo they're actually there
exactly they are racing this climb at
the top on the hardest section now Yates
was dropped Tillman had started losing
teammates already and I think only at
that point that I did I really believe
okay
do this now this is the moment it is now
or never through now he goes on the
offensive he goes on the attack over the
top of this final climb
the barber can go with him it's just an
amazing feeling to see that into Merlin
and the other TC guys and they want them
and that that was that was where the the
time trial started four times a winner
of the Tour de France winner of the
Vuelta easy head of the year to to
d'Italia victory once I accelerated and
I saw no one come with me I just stuff
it I'm gonna go for it now all or
nothing and get stuck into this and even
on this descent is taking a few seconds
I wouldn't sales taking risks on the
descents but I pushed on and went as
fast as I could
it was just an amazing feeling to get to
the bottom of the descent until next
Valley and just fear that the gap it
opened up another 30 40 seconds just in
which is almost for free if you like
because it's not really much pedaling to
do on it and it's more about the
technique and that the lines you take as
the race went on and that that gap went
up from one minute one half to two and a
half three and it was just like wow I'm
now in in reach of paint jersey and the
overall lead of the race
Chris Froome is now the virtually De
Rosa of this jus d'Italia what's a stage
it has been being out in front has
changed me and gave me even more I guess
to to fight for and I was just such an
incredible feeling very is still the
virtue Molly
who'da thought at the start of today
what
today was about fuelling and today was
about making sure that you can fuel a
ride like this all the way through to
the end and that is fundamental and so
all members of every single one of them
myself included I've been outside the
road and put in place a fuelling plan
for him to make sure that he would
absolutely not miss a beat because I
that's basically the game changer it's
certainly not easy to take on that
amount of carbohydrates every
opportunity I had I'd be putting
something else in my mouth and I think
the betta fuel played a huge part in
that obviously it's it's just a drink
it's in a bottle but he had 80 grams of
carbs from one bottle and I think I had
two beautiful drinks are on the road and
I literally went into the stage so full
already I think I was just just bursting
I felt as if I I literally cannot eat
any more right now but thankfully that's
the way I went into the race because
certainly when when I crossed that
finish line at the end I was completely
empty I had nothing left so I'm pretty
glad that I did fill up in that way
the picture of this picture Schmidt is
completely unique I've never attacked
educate out and I mean it's just
something that you don't really see very
often anymore in professional cycling
and it's and it's been a couple decades
since we since we saw someone win a
Grand Tour in that kind of fashion this
is the moment that he's been waiting for
Chris Froome is the winner of the
hundred and first edition of the Giudice